bob woodward reports that general mark
milley contemplated handing over
american security to the chinese to
thwart trump and the california recall
effort against gavin newsom as a dud i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn don't let big tech track what
you do anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
you're spending way too much on your
cell phone coverage lots of customers
already know this which is why customers
have been abandoning by droves verizon
at t t mobile and those overpriced
wireless plans that pay for the
thousands of retail stores latest social
initiatives their added perks you pay
for but never actually use instead
hundreds of thousands of smart families
are saving over 800 a year by switching
over to pure talk without having to
sacrifice coverage that's because pure
talk is on the exact same network as one
of the big three so you're getting all
of the benefits of the size and none of
the downsides of the of the actual cost
what is your excuse i made the switch
you can keep your phone keep your number
or get huge discounts on the latest
iphones and androids you can get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and if you
still want unlimited data you can get
that too and still save a fortune head
on over to puretalk.com enter your
address to check the coverage at your
home or office then shop for the plan
that's right for you you can even use
their savings calculator to see exactly
how much your family will save go to
puretalk.com enter promo code shapiro
you will save 50 off your very first
month that is puretalk.com promo code
shapiro puretalk is simply smarter
wireless well a couple of preliminary
notes first uh the greatest comic of our
generation norm mcdonald died yesterday
he had been battling cancer apparently
quietly and secretly without making that
public and he passed away if you just
want a day filled with laughs go to
youtube and just watch old clips of norm
mcdonald he's an underappreciated genius
and as jeremy boring my business partner
put it the great genius of north
macdonald is that every single nor
mcdonald fan feels like they're the only
nor mcdonald fan when in fact pretty
much everybody was in north mcdonald fan
his stuff is just hysterically funny his
memoir is one of the funniest books ever
written go check out some norm mcdonald
today in um in more generally political
news the california recall effort was a
complete and total dud newsome won with
an extraordinary percentage of the vote
he survived the recall effort by a
margin of 64 to 36
that's with 70 percent of the vote in
and um
in the question of who was going to
replace him larry elder was leading with
of the vote the california governor
recall exit polls via nbc news show that
the the desire to recall newsom
was not
was not held by a majority of
californians anywhere in the poll right
only 47 percent of of males only 46
percent of males wanted to recall them
only 38 of women wanted to recall them
only 44 of white voters wanted to recall
them only 19 of black voters wanted to
recall them so this is just a textbook
blowout and that is because california
is a completely blue state so the the
bad news for california is that
california is uh apparently irredeemable
and now in an inevitable state of
complete collapse and decline because
there is no desire to actually reverse
any of that that's been true for a while
the good news is i don't have to think
about moving back so i guess that's good
news uh that is that is pretty much what
the the recall effort shows
they did ask folks
about some of the issues that had come
up
on these uh uh in the recall effort
particularly covid policy
and what they found is that
a
large percentage of californians are
very comfortable with coveted policies
that were put forward by by gavin newsom
uh something like 46 percent of
californians said that they thought that
they were about right that this is all
pretty good they all worked just fine
in fact a significant percentage of
californians thought that the coveted
policies were actually not strict enough
they should have been stricter
apparently only 32 percent of
californians thought that the policies
were too strict
so they're getting what they deserve
right good and hard this is the h.l
mankind line about democracy being the
theory that the voters ought to get what
they want good and hard this is what
they are getting good and hard
26 of the people who voted in the recall
strongly approved of gavin newsom's
performance as governor another 28
somewhat approved so about 54
and uh you know not not a huge
percentage of people
actually
disapproved of them it's like 43
disapproved so it's a pretty heavy win
for gavin newsom for his part gavin
newsom said that this was a referendum
on trumpism which is kind of wild
donald trump number one was not on the
ballot but number two
you shouldn't be this triumphal about
surviving a recall effort in california
which is a heavily democratic state
this is like saying that ben shapiro
survived a recall effort at the daily
wire right like i
own the place the democrats own the
place so for gavin the shock would have
been if gavin newsom had actually been
recalled and let's not be
ridiculous about this the recall effort
here was significantly less likely to
succeed than the recall effort of gray
davis back in 2001-2002
back when gray davis was recalled during
that period we were like four years
removed from a republican governor the
last time california had a truly
republican governor was pete wilson in
the late 1990s
so a full generation
anyway here was gavin newsom trying to
suggest that this was his triumphant
return he had triumphed over trumpism
this is what democrats are going to try
and do by the way it's a good
reminder this is the democratic plan for
2022 and 2024 they want to run against
trump they want trump on the ballot they
want to make it all about trump
which is why if you're a republican even
if you like trump a lot you might want
to think a little bit seriously about
whether you want trump back on the
ballot because it does get democrats out
to the ballot box for sure trump is good
at republican turnout and he's even
better at democratic turnout in any case
there's gavin newsom trying to push that
point
i i said this many many times on the
campaign trail
you know
we may have defeated trump but trumpism
is not dead in this country
the big lie
january six insurrection all the voting
suppression efforts that are happening
all across this country
what's happening the assault on
fundamental rights constitutionally
protected rights of women and girls
it's a remarkable moment
in our nation's history
uh it's not a remarkable moment in our
nation's history it would have been
remarkable as if you'd been dumped
again this would be the equivalent of
the governor of alabama surviving a
recall election against a democrat like
that's that is not a particular shock
and the media portraying it as a shock
is kind of shocking in and of itself the
real shock is that it went this far
nonetheless according to
dny news
they say california basks in its
clairvoyance the future happens here
first says governor gavin newsom calling
his state america's coming attraction uh
well that's why i left by emphatically
turning back the effort to recall him
from office however mr newsom made clear
california's cherished role presaging
the politics of tomorrow was not as
significant as another larger factor in
tuesday's results the tribal politics of
today the first term democratic governor
will remain in office because in a
deeply liberal state he effectively
nationalized the recall effort as a
republican plot making a flame-throwing
radio host the trump-like face of the
opposition to polarize the electorate
along red and blue lines so the
suggestion here and this has been the
suggestion of the media is that if larry
elder had not been the candidate for the
republican party most likely to replace
gavin newsom then newsom would have done
worse in the recall effort now that may
be true in the sense that larry is a
very strong political personality with
very strong views
but again this is a heavily democrat
state the notion that he was going to
get recalled at all was probably
a bit of a pipe dream
and even when the polls narrowed
significantly and got to the point where
it was really really narrow that was
when they were not talking about any of
the people running against him if it had
not been larry they probably would have
done this to kevin cal falconer for
example
so
again the media are treating this as a
referendum on sort of conservatism more
generally
and they're attempting to make it a
referendum on trumpism and it really had
nothing to do with either it had to do
with the fact that the z heavy i can't
say it enough it's a heavy blue state
they have a super majority in the
legislature the democrats do
so if they'd replaced
newsome with any republican that would
have been a grave shock
mr newsome found success not because
what makes california different but
because of how it's like everywhere else
he dominated in california's heavily
populated democratic cities the key to
victory in a state where his party
outnumbers republicans by five million
voters by the way this should be a
reminder if you're a republican in
california things are going to get worse
not better i've been saying this since i
left
right follow me get out while the
getting is good move to a purple state
turn that state red california is a lost
cause i know there are a bunch of people
who are hanging on over there i was one
of them until a year ago
i i'm much happier now that i have left
the state the state is again in an
inexorable state of decline the voters
there are not interested in turning away
from the path that they are now trotting
they're not turning away from higher
taxes they're not turning away from more
regulation they're not turning away from
from terrible records on on crime and
horrible records on education they're
not turning away from any of that stuff
they're embracing it
they're embracing the suck so get out
while the getting is good
there's plenty of opportunity in other
states
so that is the takeaway from the
california election is that the
continued sorting effect is going to
continue
and that we are going to be a country
where the red states become redder and
the blue states become bluer and the
purple states will either shift over
into red or blue and then follow that
path inevitably
as virginia has right virginia went from
purple to blue and now it seems like
it's going to continue moving blue seems
to be the trend over in virginia
on the other hand ohio went from purple
to red and seems like it is going to get
more red over time florida moved from
purple to red and seems like it's
getting more red over time california is
going to move from blue to deep blue to
like dark night blue
that's what's going to happen in the
country and the predictable result of
that is going to be further polarization
at the federal level
so on a national level why should we
care about california because what it
actually presages is not just politics
in california what it presages is a
question whether we actually do want to
remain part of the same body politic if
we do want to remain part of the same
body politic we're going to have to
construct a system of a federal
governance in which texas can be texas
and california can be california however
california has to let texas be texas
and herein lies the rub because the
federal government has no interest when
run by democrats in allowing texas to be
texas they would like texas to be
california
and if that's the case what you're going
to end up with is a fairly ugly split
between states that wish to be left
alone and states that wish to run their
business from the top level of the
federal government
i think this is why you're hearing so
much talk these days about a quote
unquote civil war or talk about
secession or talk about the country
breaking apart
it's a serious question whenever you
form a body politic which is what
happened at the founding and what
happened again in the aftermath of the
civil war if you form a body politic
you have to decide whether you wish to
remain part of the same country and if
so what common rules can you hold at the
top level that everybody can agree to
well if the basic notion of american
government is that the federal
government's going to make all the rules
and it's just going to be a struggle for
the power of the one ring
then this country is not going to last
this way it is just not and maybe then
the best hope for a lot of conservatives
and maybe for a lot of liberals
depending on who's in control of that
federal government is uh a friendly
separation
that is what that force ages
okay not that california is the wave of
the future but the california
and its polarization is the wave of the
future and that we're going to get i
promise you in the aftermath of this
real estate values in florida are going
to go up real estate values in arizona
in texas and nevada they're going to go
up because republicans are going to
continue leaving
and maybe that's what the california
politicians want
so be it
alrighty in just a second we'll get to
the other big news of the day the coup
attempt by general mark milley it's hard
to call it anything other than that
really it's kind of an astonishing story
from bob woodward's new book we'll get
to that in just one moment first let us
talk about your sleep quality so you may
have noticed that i look a little tired
lately that's because my kids have been
a little bit sick that means that when i
am sleeping i need to sleep when i'm on
a mattress i need to sleep and that
means i need a mattress made just for me
this is where helix sleep comes in helix
sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress you
know will be perfect for the way you
sleep
everybody is unique and helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus sized sleepers so if you're looking
for a mattress you take the quiz you
order the mattress you match to the
mattress comes right to your doorship
for free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by both gq and wired up
magazine and they've been recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution for improving sleep we love our
helix sleep mattress you will too
they've got a 10 year warranty you try
it out for 100 nights at risk free
they'll pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will i promise because i
love my helix sleep mattress helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at
helixleep.com that's helixsleep.com
ben alrighty so as we discuss you know
the the role of the federal government i
think at this point
there are two possibilities for the
federal government and the continuation
thereof one is as i mentioned the
possibility that the rules at the top
level are agreed upon
they're fairly light and then we get to
live locally the way we want to live
locally san francisco gets to live like
san francisco
and texas gets to live like texas
right that that seems like a fairly good
way of doing things in fact that's kind
of what the founders proposed and then
there's system number two which is a
competition over the vast power of the
federal government
and every four years we switch our
elected dictator now the problem is this
that really only works if you think
number one the downsides of the other
guys gaining control
is still worth the upside of remaining
part of the union and two that if that
you have enough of a shot of gaining
control of the levers of power that you
can reverse a lot of the bad stuff if
you just stick in long enough right
those are the two conditions for
sticking in a very centralized power
regime one is that the people who
operate the centralized power on the
other side aren't actually going to ruin
your life in the time that they are in
control and two is that even if they
attempt to ruin your life there's still
the shot that your guy can take office
in two three years and then reverse all
of that
republicans have bought into that right
the idea is okay yeah well biden's
administration will suck but maybe in
two three years trump comes back or get
ron desantis or somebody else
now there's one factor that can militate
against that possibility and exacerbates
the possibility of a of a general crack
up in the american political system
what if
that possibility goes away not through
election fraud and not the rigging of
the rules or anything but what if the
federal government has essentially been
reduced from a system of checks and
balances
in which the downsides are mitigated and
the upsides are still available
what if those checks and balances have
been completely replaced by an
administrative state that effectively
runs on its own
in opposition to conservatives when
they're in power but in support of
democrats when they're in power
now this was the talk about the
quote-unquote permanent deep state when
donald trump was president there was
this idea that there was a career
staffers in the bureaucracy and they
spent pretty much every waking moment
attempting to thwart what the trump
administration was attempting to do
and this of course was true in large
measure okay the fact is that there were
career democrats in the state department
who really didn't like what for example
mike pompeo was trying to do at the
state department
right there were career democrats in the
department of defense who didn't like
what donald trump was trying to do
and trump didn't clear out those
administrative agencies he fired a few
people but he really didn't clear them
top to bottom
and so those administrative agencies
were able to thwart a lot of his desires
and this goes all the way back to the
reagan administration when ronald reagan
suggested he was going to dump the
department of education and then
proceeded to fund it so republicans if
like
the quote unquote deep state
it's not a conspiracy it's just the idea
that you have a bunch of staffers who
are in positions of power who feel that
they have an overall allegiance to the
institution for which they work and they
interpret that allegiance as we have a
mission in this particular institution
and no president is allowed to override
that allegiance so you effectively have
an independent body of actors who just
happen to align pretty heavily with
people inside the democratic party
so if as i say the two possibilities for
maintaining the union are one a light a
light touch at the federal level which
is not really a possibility anymore
or two that the federal level has a lot
of power
but the downsides are mitigated because
there is no kind of freewheeling
everything just gets done the way we
want to do it checks and balances
there's a check and balance to just
ramming through things right that is
mitigating factor number one and
mitigating factor number two is your guy
could take control and reverse
everything what if the mitigating
factors go away because you have an
enormous administrative state run by the
executive and the executive can do
whatever the f he wants at any time
right he can just use the cdc to cram
down an eviction moratorium
by the way that happened under trump and
then was re re-upped under under biden
or he can use the justice department to
simply stop enforcing immigration law
has happened under barack obama or osha
can be used of all places to cram down
vaccine mandates and 100 million
americans
right what if the checks and balances go
away so the downsides are now
not only not mitigated they are actually
exacerbated right the downsides of the
bad guys in your view whatever your view
is running the government the downsides
are unlimited
and not only that what if if you're on
the right you look at the federal
government you're like okay well even if
the downsides are unlimited the upsides
are also unlimited because if our guy
takes power then he can undo up what if
he can't
what if he can't what if the
administrative state
is a bulwark against conservatives but
is a tool for people on the left
okay that that happens to be kind of the
case
the administrative bureaucracy
is staffed by career professionals most
of whom graduated from
colleges with with degrees in government
and who have spent most of their working
lives
working on behalf of institutions that
are thoroughly entrenched in liberal
group think
if you walk into the regulatory agencies
of the federal government
and you actually pulled the regulatory
agencies as to exactly how those folks
vote
my guess is that it looks a lot like 80
20 democrat
and those people have an enormous amount
of power since they're writing the
actual regulations you think donald
trump is sitting there reading the
regulations binders of regulations you
think even if ron desantis were
president he'd have the ability to read
through the thousands and tens of
thousands of pages of the federal
register generated by the bureaucracy
every year the administrative threat is
a threat to liberty but it's also a
threat to the stability of the
government
because the more rigid it becomes the
more self-sustaining it becomes the less
the american people feel like they have
a bargain here unless they feel like
their voices are heard like they can
push back against a one-way ratchet in
terms of the federal government
and that's where things kind of stand
now the greatest indicator of this that
maybe i've seen in my lifetime is the
brand new story courtesy of bob woodward
in his new book
so bob woodward and robert costa have a
new book titled peril
and in this book there's a bit of a
shocking revelation the shocking
revelation is that general mark melody
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff assured his chinese counterpart
general li zhou chang of the people's
liberation army that the united states
would not strike
apparently he did this twice apparently
he was so fearful twice in the final
months of the trump administration
that the president's action might spark
a war with china he moved urgently to
avert armed conflict because number one
you have to ask yourself where did this
story come from and where did the story
come from because apparently there's
only two people on that phone call one
is mark milley and the other
is general lee chang of the people's
liberation army presumably woodward
didn't get this from the chinese which
means that mark milley is bragging about
this which is not a shock because mark
milley has a greatly inflated sense of
both his own importance and of the
historical moment right mark milley was
the one who was comparing january 6 to
an actual rex tag fire and suggesting
the entire democracy was in danger which
of course wasn't true
he he has this kind of bizarre
blown-up sense of himself
as the man standing in the gap stranding
in the breach
okay so but even if you believe that
there are ways to resist
presidential illegal orders
and number one you don't carry them out
number two you can threaten to quit
we actually have precedent for this
during the trump administration
even if it's not illegal you can
threaten to quit james mattis did it
several times before he actually quit
the secretary of defense general james
mattis
you'll recall that donald trump wanted
him to do particular things that he
didn't want to do in syria and mattis
just went to him and was like i'm not
doing that
and then trump backed down well millie
could have done the same thing he didn't
he didn't even go to congress
right milly apparently went directly to
the enemy he went directly to the
chinese government
and he said to them you know this crazy
guy in the white house man that guy's
crazy and uh and if he orders us to do
anything militarily even if it's legal
i'm just not gonna do it in fact i will
call you first
i will call you first and then you
wonder why so many conservatives worry
about the quote unquote deep state coup
because that sounds an awful lot like a
deep state i mean even alexander vinman
right the guy who is
who is phoning in the ukraine phone call
very anti-trump even he was like this is
insane because it is civilian control of
the military is a bulwark of american
republicanism
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first we have a very different
kind of sponsor for this particular
episode it's called the jordan harbinger
show it's a podcast you really should be
listening to i know every day somebody
tells you you have to listen to some
podcast or another but jordan harbinger
show is well worth the listen apple
names it one of its best of 2018 it is
aimed at making you a better informed
more critical thinker so you can get a
sense of how the world actually works
and come to your own conclusions about
what's happening even inside your own
brain each episode is a conversation
with a different fascinating guest when
i say there's something for everyone
here i really mean that in one episode
jordan talks to a hostage negotiator
from the fbi who offers techniques on
how to get people to like and trust you
which sounds pretty useful and also kind
of disturbing at the same time there's
another episode telling the story of a
cinematographer who discovered a lost
city in the jungle and made one of the
most important archaeological finds of
the century it's always fascinating
jordan's conversations with people like
oliver north or ray dalio this is stuff
that really makes you a more informed
human being we here at daily wire enjoy
the show we think you will too check out
jordanharbinger.com start for some
episode recommendations or search the
jordan harbinger show that's h-a-r-b as
in boy i n is a nancy g-e-r on apple
podcast spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts okay so according to bob
woodward's book
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff under president trump general mark
milley called up
the
head of the chinese military general
liaochang
and told him the united states would not
strike one call according to the
washington post took place on october
30th 2020 four days before the election
that unseated president trump
the other took place january 8 2021 and
two days after the capital siege carried
out by his supporters in a quest to
cancel the vote
the first call was prompted by millie's
review of intelligence suggesting the
chinese believed the united states was
preparing to attack that belief the
author's right was based on tensions
over military exercises in the south
china sea and deepened by trump's
belligerent rhetoric toward china
millie apparently called up general lee
he said quote i want to assure you the
american government is stable and
everything is going to be okay we are
not going to attack or conduct any
kinetic operations against you
in the books account millie went so far
as to pledge he would alert his
counterpart in the event of a u.s attack
stressing the rapport they'd established
through a back channel general lee you
and i have known each other for five
years now if we're going to attack i'm
going to call you ahead of time it's not
going to be a surprise
that's insane
and we're not even talking about
post-election at this point this is
still pre-election it's before ending
the january 6 stuff it's before any of
the election fraud stuff none of which
by the way justifies breaking the chain
of command in illegal ways which is
apparently what melee did to do this
well
but again this is even before any of
that this is october 30th
now
i recall that period i recall october
november december january wasn't that
long though
was that widespread talk about how the
united states was going to enter a
full-scale fighting war with the chinese
was that even on the table was anybody
even discussing that like i feel like i
would have heard about that given the
fact that president trump is a big
devotee to cable news
and cable news presumably would have
been discussing that pretty rapidly if
trump were talking about it like
what were the actual possibilities that
the chinese thought that we were going
to start a shooting war with a country
with a billion humans in it
like what does anyone actually believe
that or is milly just a delusional
thoroughly self-obsessed human being
and is it insane i mean that's insane
that he called up the chinese
even if you believed that the element of
surprise is a bit of a thing in a war
let's say that trump had issued an
actual legal order to fire on a chinese
boat in the south china sea
is mili actually going to warn the
chinese that we're about to do that
losing the fundamental element of
surprise in a military conflict also the
notion that millie would have to call
the chinese is crazy
because again we do have procedures to
defy illegal orders in the military cnn
reported on this back in september of
2018.
based on another bob woodward book
actually
because a couple of years ago there's a
bob woodward book
talking about how james mattis was
mouthing off about trump and all of the
rest of this
but cnn reported at the time
that
all of the top u.s commanders would push
back against an order from trump for a
nuclear strike if it were quote unquote
illegal
general john highton who's the top u.s
nuclear commander
said quote i provide advice to the
president he'll tell me what to do if
it's illegal guess what's going to
happen i'm going to say mr president
that's illegal guess what he's going to
do he's going to say what would be legal
and we'll come up with options of a mix
of capabilities to respond to whatever
the situation is that's the way it works
it's not that complicated
titan emphasized the us military has the
obligation to follow only legal orders
including those entailing the launch of
nuclear weapons
also
air force general robert keeler who
served as commander of u.s
u.s strategic command under obama said
there are layers of safeguards within
the system designed to ensure any order
is legal and proportionately appropriate
quote u.s nuclear forces operate under
strict civilian control only the
president of the united states can order
the employment of u.s nuclear weapons
this is a system controlled by human
beings nothing happens automatically
cnn military analyst john kirby right
now he's the spokesperson person for the
pentagon but at that point he was a
military analyst for cnn he said that
military judge advocates and general
counsel are active participants in the
decision-making process at virtually
every level from the tactical to the
strategic
he said they help ensure political
appointees and uniform commanders fully
understand and consider law of war
principles as well as the dictates of
congressional legislation before any
final decision is reached regarding the
use of armed force and defense of the
nation particularly during the planning
of combat operations so in other words
is there any circumstance under which it
would have been necessary for an
american general to go to the chinese
and say we're going to give you a heads
up on a military attack
how is that not borderline treason
i mean no matter how much you hate trump
let's say you're a democrat do you want
that same logic being applied to joe
biden do you want the generals to start
calling up
targets of american military ira and
being like yeah guys you know we're not
going to abandon those orders and if
biden threatens you it's an empty threat
in the second call place to assuage
chinese fears about the events of
january 6th lee wasn't as easily a wage
even after milly promised him quote we
are 100 steady everything's fine but
democracy can be sloppy sometimes we
remained rattled millie who did not
relay the conversation to trump
understood why the chairman 62 at the
time chosen by trump in 2018
believed the president had suffered a
mental decline after the election the
authors write a view he communicated to
house speaker nancy pelosi in a phone
call january 8.
he agreed with her evaluation trump was
unstable according to a call transcript
obtained by the authors now
again that's not illegal right millie is
allowed to talk to nancy pelosi what
he's not allowed to do is call up the
chinese and start conveying this stuff
believing that china could lash out if
it felt at risk from an unpredictable
and vengeful american president millie
took action the same day he called the
admiral overseeing u.s indo-pacific
command the military responsible for
asia and pacific and recommended
postponing military exercises in the
admiral complied milli also summoned
senior officers to review the procedures
for launching nuclear weapons saying the
president alone could give the order but
also that he millie had to be involved
which is a bit of a violation of the
chain of command looking each in the eye
melee asked the officers to affirm that
they had understood in what he
considered an oath
milly went furthest in seeking to stave
off a national security crisis but his
alarm was shared throughout the highest
ranks of the administration including
cia director gina haspel who told millie
quote we are on the way to a right-wing
coup
a right-wing coup
again there was no institutional support
for the january sixth rioters and in
fact it was a bunch of republicans who
signed off on the election in the states
and in the federal government as well
okay now
all of this is deeply dangerous stuff as
i'm suggesting if you have an
administrative bureaucracy unelected
officials who are actually making the
policy of the united states in
opposition to the elected leaders of the
united states
you have on your hands a real threat to
democracy an actual coup
right the threat to democracy lies in
unelected bureaucrats not a part of the
judicial branch or at least appointed
and voted on unelected bureaucrats
making policy in defiance of their
democratically elected bosses
that's a serious problem
and we have procedures for people saying
they don't want to follow illegal orders
what we don't have are procedures for
you calling up a foreign power and
trying to define foreign policy on your
own as an appointee of the president of
the united states in defiance of statute
and millie needs to go and he needs to
go forth with maybe he needs to be
prosecuted i mean that's that's insane
stuff
and that would hold true regardless of
who the president of the united states
is nonetheless the hatred for trump
means and this is where we are in our
politics hatred for trump means that the
democratic left expects quote unquote
deep state actors to do this sort of
stuff
they expect people in the administrative
bureaucracy to thwart republicans this
is why the ratchet only works one way
and again it's not only true when it
comes to the military infrastructure
it's true when it comes to osha it's
when it comes to the epa it's true when
it comes to the irs the ratchet only
works one way because when a republican
is in office an entire executive branch
exists to thwart him and when a democrat
exists to placate a swage and forward
all of his policy proposals
here's democratic representative john
garamendi
from california defending millie's
reported actions
i'm talking about what general miller
did you think that that's legitimate
that he would call a secret meeting and
say don't listen to the
commander-in-chief
basically
i believe that millie would do that
now did he do it well that remains to be
seen but i what i know of that uh
general
and his role as chief of staff is that
he would
call the meeting given the concerns of
an unhinged president
uh
at that period of time
okay so um there they are apparently
this is all okay
msnbc's barry mccaffrey who of course is
a general himself he said well you know
it's fine he's just trying to stop world
war three
i think what general miller was doing
and by the way routinely the chairman
the service chiefs the joint combatant
commanders routinely are in contact with
their counterparts globally part of the
the deterrence of unwanted combat
i think he felt
important to not end up with a world war
one start of a war through
miscalculation on the part of the
chinese so again i think we ought to be
fortunate we got this princeton grad
tremendous combat officer extremely
intelligent law based trying to
safeguard the transition
to a dually elected president pride
administration
now we do have diplomats
right we we have diplomats who are
available
why didn't
uh why didn't he walk across the the
office millie to
folks in the state department and say to
the secretary of state mike pompeo you
know there might be a miscalculation
here you might want to call up the
chinese and assure them that there is no
imminent military action
and the idea here is that millie was
working he was the man on the inside
okay cnn's lieutenant general mark
hurtling also defended millie
and i'm not sure how you defend the
general who is calling up the enemy and
trying to inform them about how he is
going to essentially create the military
policy on his own in defiance of the
civilian leadership
i think uh general milley took some very
prudent measures general milley isn't
going to call the the head of the
people's liberation army in china and
say hey don't worry about everything's
going on he's getting signals that other
countries are concerned as well they
should have been during this period of
time they were all watching what was
going on in the insurrection on the 5th
of january so i think general milley
didn't limit the president's power
i think if he did that would be
certainly a civil military action of of
the highest highest measure and should
be condemned but what he did was ensure
the guard rails were in place so i give
him high marks for this based on what's
described in the book
high marks okay again him going to
members of the military brass and saying
okay there's still a chain and here's
how the legalities work that's fine i
really don't have a huge problem with
that
whether it's called for or not that's
that's within his purview i'm gonna keep
focusing on he called up the chinese
government
right after they had unleashed by the
way worldwide virus he called up the
chinese government
and told them
about what america's military plans
would or would not be this of course led
president trump to fire back here as
president trump yesterday
first of all if it is actually true
which is hard to believe
that he would have called
china
and done these things and was willing to
advise them of an attack or in advance
of an attack that's treason for him to
say
that i would even think about attacking
china i think he's trying to just get
out of his incompetent withdrawal out of
afghanistan
okay so trump is not wrong about this
and it does speak to the fact that once
the bureaucracy is entrenched it stays
entrenched which brings us to
afghanistan we'll get to that in just
one moment because americans are still
trapped there we're now in like day 16
day 17 of americans being trapped in
afghanistan with nobody on the ground
over there we'll get to that in a second
first if you've been having trouble
falling asleep or staying asleep one of
the best things you could do is start
getting enough magnesium don't run to
the store and just buy the first
magnesium supplement you find most
magnesium supplements use the two
cheapest synthetic forms they are not
full spectrum so they won't fix your
magnesium deficiency or help you sleep
better there are actually seven unique
forms of magnesium you have to get all
of them if you want to experience the
calming sleep enhancing effects that's
why i recommend magnesium breakthrough
by buy optimizers simply take two
capsules before you go to bed you'll be
amazed by how much better you sleep and
by how much more rested you feel when
you wake up for an exclusive offer for
my listeners go to
www.magbreakthrough.com
shapiro code shapiro10 save 10 when you
try magnesium at breakthrough and one
more thing for a limited time buy
optimizers is also giving away free
bottles of their best selling products
p3om and mass designs with select
purchases go to www.magbreakthrough.com
shapiro right now get your exclusive 10
discount plus the chance to get more
than 50 bucks worth of supplements for
free that's
www.magbreakthrough.com shapiro for that
10 discount and use code shapiro 10 to
save that 10 percent alrighty we'll get
to afghanistan and the lack of
accountability that
is is throughout the administrative
state first last week joe biden
announced his authoritarian vaccine
mandate it's meant to force all
companies with over 100 employees to
either mandate vaccines or test their
employees for cove at least once per
week if you haven't heard already we're
not going to do that here at daily wire
because we don't think the federal
government has the authority to do any
of this for this we could face up to
fourteen 000 for every single violation
which could destroy us which is why we
are taking them to court and we are
calling on you for your support if you
join us as a daily wire member right now
you'll be giving us the resources we
need to take this fight all the way to
the supreme court if necessary head on
over to dailywire.com subscribe use code
do not comply at checkout for 25 off
americans have been far too willing to
see their freedoms to authoritarian
bureaucrats in the name of public health
enough is enough so please stand with us
at the daily wire most importantly with
the rights of all american citizens
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so general mark milley remember he's
part of a bureaucracy that no one will
ever get fired right no one is going to
lose their job for incompetence so long
as they carry out the wishes of a
democratic president so we have watched
an extraordinarily botched operation in
afghanistan
general mark milley it is kind of
amazing that mark milley called up
the chinese to assure them that we
wouldn't do anything that offended their
tender sensibilities while trump was
president meanwhile general mark milley
in the entire pentagon was working with
the bite administration to make nice
with the taliban so that's that's really
just wonderful
and apparently droning randos so that's
exciting as well rand paul
asked
senator secretary of state tony blinken
yesterday about this because on the way
out of afghanistan
after the isis k attack which is like
the special k of isis attack on american
troops in afghanistan while they were
trying to evacuate folks
you'll recall that after that on the way
out
there was a drone attack by the american
military and according to the new york
times we basically killed an afghan
translator and many members of his
family including children rand paul
asked secretary of state tony blinken uh
do you have any idea who he droned and
lincoln's like nope
so question is anyone getting fired for
that like what does it take to get fired
in the pentagon
and if you can't get fired who's
actually in control
that's the real question maybe when a
democratic president the answer is the
democratic president is in control but
when a republican president is president
then the bureaucracy is in control here
is senator rand paul with tony blinken
the guy the biden administration droned
was he an aid worker or an isis k
operative
the
administration is of course reviewing
that uh that strike
uh and i'm sure that uh you know full
assessment will be will be for you i
don't know if it was an aid worker or an
isis k operative uh i can't speak to
that and i can't speak to that in this
setting in any event so you don't know
or won't tell us uh i don't i don't know
because we're reviewing it
well see you think you'd kind of know
before you off somebody with a predator
drone
yeah
yes i mean
sure like
yeah i mean that's kind of hard to argue
with
meanwhile tony blinken keeps saying we
didn't see this coming so then why are
you still working why are you still in
office and the answer is because if
you're part of the democratic blob you
can't lose your job for pretty much any
reasons other than just kind of
offending the president but other than
that you're going to stay there forever
no matter how incompetent you are and
then when a republican enters office
he's not going to fire any of these
career staffers he's going to keep him
there because if he doesn't keep them
there then who's going to fill those
gaps
the answer is whoever's elected the next
republican president needs to clean
house and i mean mass firings i mean
everybody goes i mean this place gets
shut down top to bottom
here is secretary of state anthony we
had no idea by the way everybody knew
who was watching this for five seconds
this is gonna happen if you did this the
way you did it
you didn't take a genius to figure this
out
i wrote a novel like five years ago in
which the first chapter is this
happening
it wasn't because i was watching
afghanistan closely it's because it was
patently obvious to anybody that if you
would draw all support for the afghan
military and hand the country back to
the taliban bad crap was going to follow
here's tony blinken being an idiot
we the intelligence community did not
say
that the country-wide collapse of all
meaningful resistance would be likely to
occur in a matter of days and uh and you
referenced uh chairman millie as i did
earlier
nothing that
that he saw uh that i saw that we saw
suggested that this government and
security force would collapse in a
matter of 11 days and you're right that
i think we need to look back at all of
this
oh you need to look back at all this but
has anybody been fired will anybody be
fired senator josh hawley is asking that
question yesterday he said that he's
going to slow walk joe biden's foreign
policy nominees until the top officials
who oversaw all of this lose their jobs
he says he's going to object to
confirming nominees for state and
defense by unanimous consent unless
anthony blinken lloyd austin the
secretary of defense and nsa jake
sullivan all resign
he says they should take responsibility
for their failures but here's the thing
none of them are going to resign because
their failures are not their own their
joe biden's failures and if they had
happened under president trump they
would have obstructing trump's policy
and then trump had fired them there
would have been a hue and cry that trump
was getting rid of career officials see
when democrats get rid of career
officials or termed officials it's no
big deal
in fact joe biden recently attempted to
fire a bunch of trump appointees to
sort of non-partisan boards in the very
end of his administration and included
some folks like kaylee mcinanny but it
also included some some people like
lieutenant general
like general mcmaster
and biden was like i just don't like you
so i'm gonna try and fire you even
though you actually have terms right
these are not fireable positions
and nobody in the media seem to care
very much about that
norms only exist when they can be used
as a club against republicans
all of this is going to break the
country it really is
by the way our intelligence folks are
they going to get fired because
apparently intelligence experts are now
saying al qaeda could reform inside
afghanistan they originally said it
could reform within one to two years
but apparently al qaeda's already there
which we already knew so weld on
everybody
the reason that i keep coming back to
the centralizing point about the
administrative bureaucracy is because if
the country breaks is going to be
because people there is no incentive
structure for people to stay within the
structure you have to give people
something if you want them to remain
inside a structure that takes 40 percent
of their money 30 of their money and
restricts every area of their life there
has to be some guarantee on the other
end and the guarantee on the other end
cannot simply be that people you
disagree with are going to govern every
aspect of your life
it is why people are seeing movement to
red states as an escape they are seeing
it as a way of avoiding blue state
governance
they're moving for a reason the sorting
is happening and if the response by the
democrats and their friends in the
bureaucracy is to tighten their grip
to harden their defenses
to become more sclerotic
to to become less responsive to cut off
all the feedback loops
you're going to break the thing you are
and that is the direction that we are
moving right now on everything from
defense to afghanistan to kovid
the attempts to grip everything
incredibly tightly are going to lead to
the
tummy sort of once said that coaching a
baseball team is sort of like holding a
dove you want to hold it tight enough
that the dove doesn't escape but you
don't want to hold it so tight that you
crush the dove
you could say the federal government is
sort of the same thing but the goal of
the federal government should be to be
strong enough to maintain the union but
not strong enough to actually destroy
the union
and it seems as though we are moving
very rapidly in the direction of strong
enough to destroy the union
and they'd rather crush the dove then
allow the dove to breathe a little bit
and the predictable result of that is
not gonna the tighter you grip the more
things are gonna break
you're not creating stability you're
actually creating radical instability
in this entire process and that radical
instability is going to lead to a lot of
very bad things
it's not going to lead to an amicable
amicable breakup like it's not just not
going to be an amicable amicable divorce
the high likelihood is that things get
uglier as time goes on
because in a desire for top down
dominant you are alienating everybody
and when they have no place left to go
because you are using the federal
government as the crammed down power
through the power of an unelected
administrative bureaucracy the only
check apparently being the supreme court
i mean really we now have two branches
of the american government the
administrative state and the supreme
court and that's it
and if the democrats simply pack the
supreme court that check goes away too
then uh i will say that the end of the
american republican experiment uh would
would then be at an end
on that depressing note we'll have
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
a little bit later on in the meantime go
check out the michael knowles show that
is available right now i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavo
wiedowsky
producer bradford carrington host
producer justin barbour the show is
edited by adam syavets audio is mixed by
mike caromina hair and makeup is by
fabiola cristina production assistant
jessica kranz the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021
the california recall effort fails joint
chiefs chairman mark milley flirts with
treason and the funniest man in the
world dies unexpectedly check it out on
the michael knowles show